[Applause]
all right
we've been working hard to
be ready for our first human and
obviously we want to be extremely
careful
uh and certain that that it will work
well before putting a device in a human
but we're
we're submitted I think most of our
paperwork to the FDA and we're we think
probably in about six months we should
be able to have uphost neural Link in a
human so
so for uh the the first two applications
we're going to aim for in humans um are
restoring vision
and uh
I think this is like notable in that
even if someone has never had Vision
ever like they were born blind we
believe they could they can we can still
restore vision
um so
uh because the visual part of the the
visual part of the cortex is still still
there
so
uh yeah even if they've never seen
before
uh we're confident that they could they
could see
um
and then the uh the other application
being in the motor cortex uh where we
would initially enable someone who uh
has no ability to almost no ability to
operate their
their muscles you know sort of like a
sort of Stephen Hawking type situation
and enable them to operate their phone
faster than someone who has Working
Hands So
uh I mean as miraculous as it may sound
uh
we're confident that it is possible to
restore full body functionality to
someone who has a severed spinal cord
so yeah
[Applause]
and um
here you can see
sake it's one of other monkeys typing on
a keyboard
this is telepathic typing so to be clear
this is the
he's not actually using a keyboard he's
moving
the cursor with his mind uh to the
highlighted key it's also important to
show that
um sake actually likes doing the demo
um and it's not like strapped to the
chair or anything
so uh it's
yeah so
um
the monkeys actually enjoy doing the
demos because they and they get the
banana smoothie and it's kind of a fun
game